two for every sequel that successfully
clawed its way into movie theaters
there's an
unmade take that wowed on paper but
floundered in development
the predator franchise has seen more
than a few proposed sequels hit the
cutting room floor and we break them
down right here
the concept of pitting xenomorphs
against predators first appeared in the
anthology comic book series dark horse
presents in 1989.
a year later predator 2 further indulged
a showdown with an easter egg of a
xenomorph
skull in a predator trophy case but the
alien vs predator concept didn't make
earnest moves towards the big screen
until 1991 when future hellboy co-writer
peter briggs
penned a spec script briggs initial
draft
titled the hunt alien vs predator
adheres closely to the original dark
horse comic penned by randy stradley
taking place off world and in the future
brick's script
focuses on a clan of predators who use
planets seeded with xenomorph eggs as
hunting grounds as a challenge their
leader includes a
queen face hugger in the batch of eggs
unleashed on a jungle planet
as you'd imagine this does not go well
in 1992
aliens magazine reported that roland
emmerich was attached to direct
though nothing came of it emmerich and
his creative partner dean devlin were
especially keen on the idea of the
predator alien hybrid only hinted at in
briggs draft
fox effectively shelved the project in
1993
after producer joe roth left the studio
in 2002 producer john davis rejected a
treatment
penned by james demonico and kevin fox
on the basis that he wanted to set the
film
on earth and move away from the dark
horse comics
at the end of predator 2 an elder
predator rewards mike harrigan with a
trophy
the gift is an antique pistol engraved
with the inscription
rafael adelini 1715 it's a memorable
moment that hints at just how long the
predators have been terrorizing our
planet
it also raises a whole swath of
questions that it turns out were
intended to find answers in a sequel
that
never materialized as director writer
duo jim and john thomas note in the
predator 2 director's commentary they
were constantly toying around with the
idea of a predator film
set on earth in a time before modern
weapons
the brothers have said we played around
on the set with doing something
historical
like in a time where you had nothing but
steam engines and flintlocks and you
were up against something like the
predator
that could be fun the brothers
brainstorming sessions never
materialized into anything concrete
and yet while we were robbed of a big
screen predator period piece that didn't
stop dark horse comics from picking up
the thomas brothers enticing engraved
pistol and
running with it published in july 1996
and written by henry gilroy predator
1718 tells the story of rafael
adelini his pistol and how the predators
in predator 2
came to acquire it set in the bermuda
triangle the comic paints atellini as a
pirate captain suddenly faced with a
rebellious crew
and an unlikely alien ally before
earning his first screenwriting credit
on 2010's predators
alex litvak worked at 20th century fox
in the 1990s
he's talked about how the studio's
attitude at the time was that you
couldn't make another predator movie
without the original film star arnold
schwarzenegger
responding to this limitation litvak
pitched a sequel that envisioned the
triumphant return of schwarzenegger's
major allen dutch
schaefer litvak's pitch took place
directly
after the events of the original
predator as the script tells it the
whole affair from the first film has
been classified and
dutch is living out his days in exile
then a predator ship crashes at a remote
location and the government taps dutch
to lead a spry team of commandos to
investigate
when they finally reach the ship a group
of predators emerge with one target
dutch he's the one that got away and
they've come back to claim their prize
as litvack explains the pitch was a
pointed attempt
to seduce schwarzenegger whether
litvak's proposed script even made it to
the actor
is unclear in any case the studio
resolved that schwarzenegger was still
off the table and the pitch never saw
the light of day
while waiting to work on desperado in
the early 1990s robert rodriguez wrote a
script for a third predator film
an unconfirmed copy of his script has
since made the rounds on the internet
and it is
to put it mildly completely bananas
the story begins on an alien planet
where a group of humans outfitted in
predator armor
attack a spanish galleon the cloaked
attackers overwhelm the ship and
transport their captive
dutch from the first film to a prison
planet the planet
also happens to be a gladiatorial
training ground for teen
predators replete with among other
things human alien hybrids
rodriguez approached arnold
schwarzenegger about returning to his
original role as dutch
supposedly there was even a role in the
script written for jean-claude van damme
rodriguez's script would ultimately
morph into 2010's predators
thanks to an extensive overhaul by alex
litvak and michael finch
however at the time fox passed on the
script because rodriguez's sequel
was simply too ambitious and expensive
while working on 2007's aliens vs
predator requiem as a visual effects
consultant liam o'donnell drafted a
sequel treatment
o'donnell's idea for aliens vs predator
3
took place on a future earth ravaged by
climate change where mankind has
reverse engineered advanced interstellar
travel with technology recovered from
predator weapons
however the fuel that powers this
space-faring tech is derived from a rare
mineral only found in southern africa
the last continent free from the vice
grip of the weyland yutani corporation
the warming of the planet causes the
release of the original alien vs
predator queen
from her icy tomb and the film ends with
a third act
three-way fight between a predator alien
and human
the treatment was ultimately scrapped
for two reasons first
as o'donnell puts it after the addition
of the predator home planet to requiem
there was an assumption that if they did
a third movie it had to be in space
second upon its release aliens vs
predator requiem failed miserably at the
box office
basically scrapping any hope for a
sequel in 2015 vincenzo natali tweeted a
slew of concept art for
among other things a tentative predator
reboot the visual pitch offers a brief
glimpse into what we could have seen
an expressionistic jungle war zone a
sleek and spiky predator
and a brutal gladiatorial showdown
natali pitched his take on what would
ultimately become predators with nothing
but a log line
predators hunt humans on their planet
natali has elaborated on his visual
treatment
when i was called in to pitch there was
nothing there was no script
there was only the notion that this was
going to take place on a predator planet
i think there was a dangerous game
aspect to it with humans being hunted by
predators
i met with robert rodriguez and some
executives and i just did a whole bunch
of drawings
nothing ever came from that bunch of
drawings and that's a shame because the
idea of the director of cube and splice
taking a stab at a predator movie
sounds like a match made in sci-fi
horror heaven
in 2010 director nimrod antal and
producer robert rodriguez revitalized
the franchise with predators an
action-packed sequel set on an alien
planet turned hunting ground
the honor obsessed aliens use a
planetary game preserve to test their
abilities hunting down humans
as well as creatures from other planets
by the end
only two survivors remain as the pair
catch their breath at the end of the
film
a new hunt begins and our heroes realize
that they have to escape now
let's find a way off this planet
despite its obvious sequel setup a
predator's follow-up has yet to
materialize
which makes co-writer alex litvak's
enticing proposal for a direct sequel an
absolute knife twist litvak has
described his pitch for predators 2
as die hard on a predator ship in lit
vox sequel
royce and isabel let the predators catch
them they are then brought aboard the
ship that the aliens use to transport
people to the planet they break out of
their cells and as they attempt to seize
control of the ship
die hard in space ensues eventually our
heroes make it back to earth and then
per litvak we land and realize it's the
future
all along we thought this was happening
now but what if these guys have been on
ice for 300 years the hatch opens and
the space marines come in
this move would have once again merged
the alien and predator franchises under
one roof
as litvak tells it although 20th century
fox was enthusiastic his proposed sequel
never got off the ground
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
predator are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one